[Music]
the global markets move
billions in value daily creating massive
amounts of data in the process
as the volume variety and complexity of
market and alternative data expands
financial data publishers face mounting
pressure to modernize and deliver their
processes in an increasingly
latency sensitive world and consumers
are demanding more
there's a 60 year-over-year increase in
demand for alternative data sets
and 90 of financial firms are forecast
to use the cloud
for their market data in four years
right now
commercial data publishers have several
ways of sharing data sets with their
customers and partners
including ftp email and access to
publisher apis
these can involve a number of steps
hosting data sets on a remote system
making multiple copies of files for each
consumer and letting consumers fetch the
data with the right entitlements
unfortunately this can result in data
set fragmentation
and access control matrices that are
hard to rationalize
on top of that publishers face
operational overhead managing multiple
copies of the same data which becomes
expensive and hard to scale up with
consumer demand
difficulty in tracking with whom they've
shared data sets and which entitlements
are granted
and increase innovation friction from
the support of legacy processes and
infrastructure and it isn't easy for
consumers either
getting the data from the publisher is
just the beginning of your journey to
making that data useful
once you fetch the data set from
publishers you're tasked with ingesting
normalizing storing and integrating it
into your own applications and analytics
pipelines
this needs specialized skill sets and
there's usually a long fulfillment
process to retrieve and get value out of
data
today data customers expect ease
flexibility and cost efficiency
data share is an open source solution
available in the google cloud
marketplace to exchange commercial data
sets securely and easily
it helps organize third-party data
making it accessible and useful to
exchanges
analysts aggregators consumers and
fintechs
with market data in the cloud the entire
financial services ecosystem
can come together to exchange data
securely and easily
with datashare data publishers can load
and transform data once
into the cloud and entitle it across
various dimensions
from a single source to meet customer
demands and make sharing data sets easy
and secure
you can even expand your reach by
onboarding your already licensed and
entitled data sets in the google cloud
marketplace
under the financial services solutions
category where new customers can shop
for
and view your data sets here's how it
works the data publisher loads their
source data into bigquery
google cloud's fully managed petabyte
scale serverless data warehouse
through datashare's fine grain access
control policies
publishers can entitle and administer
data sets and table views
publishers control licensing while
google cloud's infrastructure takes care
of the data delivery to consumers on
google cloud
with datashare's scale and centralized
policy controls
publishers can reduce their operational
risk choose how you want to share data
through views
instead of making copies of the same
data set you can push data sets quickly
to existing customers
with data exchanges made immediately
ready to query
an integrating product feedback on the
shape of the data can be as simple as
modifying the embedded transformation
directives
written in sql for your views for
consumers
data is immediately consumable as soon
as it lands in bigquery
we're leaving the toil of downloading
and ingesting data you can easily access
entitled data sets by querying right
from bigquery itself
once you're entitled you can rapidly
start to get value out of that data
unlock new revenue streams and with less
time spent on data wrangling
spend more time on solving business
problems and data share isn't just for
financial markets
it can be used for retail health care
telecommunications
and anytime you want to open up new
revenue streams by distributing your
data at scale
to learn more check out the financial
services solutions page
and stay tuned for the next episode on
selling data on the google cloud
marketplace
[Music]
you